τεκχνολογία πόσο αλλάζουν τα πράγματα ανδενείς ε ενεργός και να επιμορφώνε τε συνεχός σε εκτς
πίσ εκτός παιχνητιού υπές μια λέξη πρ και θέλασ ρωτήσως να οικονομικό έναναλητίά ν θέωρις
η γραφιοκρατία ναι ένα εμπόδιο στην οικονομία θα έλεγα κολεύει την οικονόμια νε υτεράστιο κόστος
είναι έ από τα δύο τρία πιο μεγάλα κόστη που υπάρχουν και αποιο δήποτε επιχειρηματία
τον έχεις προσωπικό να ασχολείται όλη ημέρα με γραφειοκρατικά θέματα που δεν είναι θέματα παραγωγικότητας
και όταν με το καλό επιτύχουμε τη λέγομενη ψηφιακή μετάβαση ένας από τους μεγαλύτερους τόχους
το ώραμα είναι να μειωθεί η γραφείο κρατία και οι διαφορά και η διαπλοκή γιατί
αν υπάρχει μια πιο επιταχει μενοι κατάσταση πραγμάτων όσον αφορά τη ην συνεργασία του ιδιοτικού
το μέα με το δημόσιο δομα γιατί θέλοντας και μή έχεις πάρα απόλά πραγματοπρέπει να
κάνεις και χρειάζονται οι εγκρίσεις ι αποφάσεις του δημοσίου αν αυτά γίνονται από το δικό
σου χώρο πολύ πιο γρήγορα και χωρίς ταχαρτώσημα και τη χαρτούρα και τα όλα αυτά
που κάναμε για πάρα πό λλά χρόνια και μας σπαταλούσα χρόνο τότε σίγουρα θα είναι
μια όθηση για την επιχιρηματικότητα στην κύπρο το ίδυο μα το λένε και επενδητές όταν
έρθουν στην κύπρο ένα από τα μεγαλύτερα τους προβλήματα ήταν ταπιογρατία οι γραφιοκρατία το κεγονός
ότι τα διάφορα συστήματα του δημοσίου δεν επικοινωνού μεταξύ τους αι τι νας ένας δυνητικός
επενδητή θαπρα επηγαίνησε διάφορες κρατικές υπηρεσίες για να παίρνει εγκρίσεις ενώ μημενη μια κεντρική πλατφόρμα
θα μπορούσε όλα να γίνονται τα φτό χρονα είναιατεράστει ο κόστος καείναι εδώ που έχουμε
ιστερίσει σαν κράδος εδώ και πάρα πολλά χρονια θέλα σερωτήσω υπήρξεν πολλέσιση στο προεγομενο διάστημα
ήσουν και σε ένα μέρος από αυτέροντας συζητήσιω για τα επιτόκια πήρε την άνοδο και
ευτυχώς και που το περιμέναμε πήρε σηα